Dans ce chapitre, on va fournir le cadre
pour réfléchir aux environnements informatiques
qui peuvent s'appliquer aussi bien à ton ordinateur portable
qu'aux supercalculateurs
à la fin de ce chapitre
tu comprendras le concept fondamental des ressources informatiques
et comment elles sont liées entre elles
alors, que sont les ressources informatiques ? Simplement,
ce sont les composants qui constituent un système informatique
on a le CPU, ou unité centrale de traitement,
qui exécute la plupart des instructions, on a la mémoire
ou RAM, qui stocke temporairement les données
et les instructions des programmes
et on a les GPU, ou unités de traitement graphique,
qui sont conçus pour le rendu graphique
mais peuvent aussi être utilisés pour des tâches de calcul général
nécessitant beaucoup de traitement parallèle
comme les simulations scientifiques, l'analyse de données ou le machine learning
ces ressources travaillent ensemble pour exécuter des programmes
et chacune a ses propres unités de mesure
par exemple, les unités CPU se mesurent en cœurs
et en fréquence d'horloge, tandis que la mémoire se mesure en octets
en giga, méga et téraoctets
pour chacun de nos problèmes
on aura besoin d'un ensemble de ressources
pour les exécuter
il est crucial de prendre en compte les ressources nécessaires pour les exécuter
efficacement ; l'endroit où les composants du programme sont exécutés
et la bande passante de l'infrastructure qui les relie
jouent un rôle important
dans la performance globale
par exemple, un GPU peut être rapide pour calculer certaines parties
de notre programme, mais si le chargement de notre programme dans la mémoire du GPU
prend plus de temps que prévu
il peut être plus rapide d'utiliser le CPU à la place. Maintenant,
parlons du dimensionnement des ressources classiques
on a deux approches : le scaling vertical
et le scaling horizontal. Le scaling vertical consiste à augmenter
la puissance d'une seule ressource
comme utiliser un CPU plus puissant ou plus de mémoire
au sein d'un seul nœud physique
où un nœud est une unité d'un cluster de calcul encapsulant plusieurs
ressources en son sein. Le scaling horizontal
consiste à ajouter plus de ressources
comme plusieurs CPU ou GPU
pour travailler ensemble sur un seul nœud ou plusieurs nœuds
les deux approches ont leurs propres avantages
et inconvénients, et le choix dépend du cas d'usage spécifique
et des exigences. Introduisons un nouveau type de ressource :
les ressources quantiques. Les ressources quantiques traitent l'information quantique
avec une unité de traitement quantique, ou QPU. Un QPU
est l'ensemble du système responsable
d'accepter un jeu d'instructions quantiques exécutable
ou un quantum circuit et de retourner
une réponse précise. Ça signifie que
le QPU comprend un ou plusieurs puces quantiques
par exemple un processeur quantique IBM
ainsi que plusieurs composants supplémentaires
dans un réfrigérateur à dilution
qui refroidit la puce quantique
tels que des amplificateurs quantiques, de l'électronique de contrôle
et l'ordinateur classique requis
pour des tâches comme la conservation des instructions
et des formes d'onde en mémoire, l'accumulation des résultats
et le décodage futur de correction d'erreurs
en général, les ressources quantiques sont mesurées
selon leur qualité, l'échelle de fidélité en couches
le nombre de qubits
et la vitesse des opérations en couches de circuit par
seconde, ou CLOPS. Aujourd'hui, on va traiter la puce quantique
comme une unité de mesure, à la façon dont les systèmes de gestion des ressources
traitent les GPU — pas par le nombre de cœurs,
mais par l'unité entière. Qu'en est-il du scaling ?
Comme pour les ressources classiques, le scaling des ressources quantiques peut
aussi être catégorisé en vertical
et horizontal. Le scaling vertical
consisterait à augmenter le nombre de qubits par chiplet
ou par puce
le scaling horizontal consisterait à connecter des puces
avec des coupleurs ou des interconnexions classiques
maintenant que cette définition est posée
parlons de la gestion des ressources
la gestion des ressources dans une infrastructure informatique désigne
le processus de planification,
d'allocation et de contrôle de l'utilisation des ressources de calcul
telles que le CPU, la mémoire, le stockage
et la bande passante réseau, pour assurer une utilisation
efficace et optimale des ressources
tu peux penser à la gestion des ressources
comme à un jeu de Tetris multidimensionnel où les blocs
représentent les besoins de tes jobs
et chaque dimension est une unité de ressource. La tâche générale
est de faire rentrer ces blocs de jobs dans le cube
de toutes tes ressources disponibles. La gestion des ressources
est une tâche très complexe, et les différents centres de calcul mettent en œuvre
des stratégies différentes pour configurer leur infrastructure
selon les besoins spécifiques de leurs utilisateurs
pour appliquer les concepts qu'on vient d'apprendre, on va utiliser
Slurm. Slurm est un logiciel open source
pour la gestion des ressources
à des fins de démonstration,
j'ai une configuration locale avec trois nœuds virtuels
on peut obtenir des informations sur ces ressources de calcul
en exécutant la commande scontrol
on a deux partitions, ou groupes de nœuds :
normal et quantum. La partition normal est composée de nœuds
qui ont accès uniquement aux ressources classiques
et la partition quantum a accès aux ressources quantiques
commençons d'abord par le simple
exemple classique hello world avec Slurm
d'abord, on a besoin du programme hello world lui-même.
Et voici notre programme qui affiche simplement hello
world.
Maintenant, on doit indiquer au gestionnaire de ressources
les ressources dont on a besoin pour exécuter ce programme
comme on l'a vu, Slurm offre un moyen de spécifier
toutes les métadonnées d'un job via
un script shell
avec des annotations spécifiques à Slurm
ces annotations te permettent de spécifier les besoins en ressources,
les paramètres d'ordonnancement et plus encore.
On peut vérifier notre script de soumission
et voici la spécification de la partition,
combien de nœuds on a besoin, combien de tâches par nœud on va
exécuter, combien de CPUs par tâche on va utiliser
et quel script on veut lancer
et voilà notre programme hello world.
Pour soumettre notre job à l'exécution, on a juste besoin de lancer
une seule commande, qui est sbatch
et de fournir notre script comme argument
on peut vérifier la file d'exécution
et voir que notre programme hello world est en cours d'exécution
sur la partition normal sur le nœud c1
une fois le job terminé, on peut vérifier les résultats
en regardant le fichier de sortie.
Et c'est tout.
On s'intéresse aussi à l'utilisation des ressources quantiques
alors créons un simple programme hello world avec Qiskit.
Voici notre programme Qiskit qui contient toutes les
étapes nécessaires de création du circuit,
d'optimisation, d'exécution et de post-traitement.
Et voici tous les concepts de programmation dont on a parlé :
quantum circuit, transpiler
et les primitives Qiskit
maintenant on doit créer un script de soumission
comme avant, mais ici on spécifie
les besoins en ressources quantiques
puisqu'on a spécifié les ressources
et la partition du cluster
indiquant quelles ressources quantiques sont disponibles
les primitives Qiskit vont utiliser
les ressources allouées pour exécuter les calculs quantiques.
Maintenant on doit lancer notre programme.
Et une fois le job terminé, on peut vérifier les résultats.
Et voilà notre valeur d'espérance.
Et c'est tout pour la gestion des ressources.
Dans la prochaine section, on va parler
des modèles de programmation